with the decline of symmetric encryption
algorithms of private message encryption
new cypher suits came into light the
glaring issue with symmetric algorithms
was key exchange
having to pass secret keys is a risk on
its own right
and that we were unable to solve in a
lot of scenarios
thankfully dsl algorithm has managed to
solve this problem
the use cases for this cipher is rather
niche but crucial nonetheless
let's take a look at the topics we need
to cover in today's video
we first get a recap on what asymmetric
encryption is
and how is it any different from
symmetric encryption
we learn what digital signatures are and
how they are used in today's world
next we understand the digital signature
algorithm and see how it works step by
step
finally we learn about the advantages
dsa provides
when it comes to managing digital
signatures in a corporate and a personal
environment
let's take a look at asymmetric
encryption
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key
the public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit
and the private key is used to decrypt
the data transit
this pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message
the public keys can be shared by a
messaging blog post or key servers
since there are no restrictions as you
can see in the image
the two keys working in the system the
sender first encrypts the message using
the receiver's private key
after which we receive the ciphertext
the ciphertest is then transmitted to
the receiver without any other key
on getting the ciphertext the receiver
can use his or own private key
to decrypt the information and get the
clear text back
there has been no requirement of any key
exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetry key cryptography the
public key known to everyone cannot be
used to decrypt messages
and the private key which can decrypt
messages need not be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
for as often as long as possible
in this example we have two people nancy
and john
if nancy wants to send a message to john
john's public key should be used to
encrypt the information
the cipher text is then transferred to
john who can use his private key
to decrypt the data and get the plain
text back
this goes to highlight how we have
overcome the problem of key sharing when
it comes to asymmetric encryption
now that we have a proper revision let's
understand what digital signatures are
before moving on to the algorithm
the objective of digital signatures is
to authenticate and verify
documents and data this is necessary to
avoid tampering and digital modification
or forgery of any kind during the
transmission of official documents
they work on the public key cryptography
architecture with
one exception typically an asymmetric
key system
encrypts using a public key and decrypts
the private key
for digital signatures however the
reverse is true
the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key
because the keys are inked together
decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document
therefore verifying the signature's
provenance
let's go through each step to understand
the procedure thoroughly
in step 1 we have m which is the
original plain text message
and it is passed on to a hash function
denoted by h
to create a digest
next it bundles the message together
with the hash digest
and encrypts it using the sender's
private key
it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender's public key
once the message is decrypted it is
passed through the same hash function
each hash to generate a similar digest
it compares the newly generated hash
with the bundled hash value received
along with the message
if they match it verifies data integrity
in many instances they provide a layer
of validation and security messages
through non-secure channel properly
implemented
a digital signature gives the receiver
reason to believe that the message was
sent by the claimed sender
digital signatures are equivalent to
traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects
but properly implemented digital
signatures are more difficult to forge
than the handwritten type
digital signature schemes in the sense
used here are cryptographically based
and must be implemented properly to be
effective they can also provide
non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message
while also claiming their private key
remains secret
further some non-repudiation schemes
offer a timestamp for the digital
signature
so that even if the private key is
exposed the signature is valid
to implement the concept of digital
signature in real world
we have two primary algorithms to follow
the rsa algorithm
and the ds algorithm but the latter is a
topic of learning today
so let's go ahead and see what the
digital signature algorithm
is supposed to do
digital signature algorithm is fips
standard which is a federal
information processing standard for
digital signatures
it was proposed in 1991 and globally
standardized in 1994
by the national institute of standards
and technology also known as the nist
it functions on the framework of modular
exponential
and discrete logarithmic problems which
are difficult to compute as a force
brute system
unlike dsa most signature types are
generated by signing message digest with
the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data since just the message digest is
signed
the signature is generally much smaller
compared to the data that was saying
as a result digital signatures impose
less load on processors at the time
of signing execution and they use small
volumes of bandwidth
dsa on the other hand does not encrypt
message digest using private key
or decrypt message digest using public
key instead
it uses mathematical functions to create
a digital signature
consisting of two 160 bit numbers which
are originated from the message digest
and the private key
dc's make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature
but the authorization process is much
more complicated when compared with rsa
dsa also provides three benefits which
is the message authentication
integrity verification and
non-repardiation
in the image we can see the entire
process of dsf validation
a plain text message is passed on to a
hash function
where the digest is generated which is
passed on to a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g of
random variable
k and the private key of the sender
the outputs are then bundled onto a
single pack with a plain text and sent
to the receiver
the two outputs we receive from the
signing functions are the two 160 bit
numbers
denoted by s and r
on the receiver end we pass the plain
text to the same hash function
to regenerate the message digest it is
passed on to verification function
which has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender
global variable g and snr received from
the sender
the value generated by the function is
then compared to r
if they match then the verification
process is complete
and data integrity is verified this was
an overview of the way the dsa algorithm
works
you already know it depends on
logarithmic functions to calculate the
outputs
so let us see how we can do the same in
our next section
we have three phases here the first of
which is key generation
to generate the keys we need some
prerequisites
we'd select a queue which becomes a
prime divisor
we select a prime number p such that p
minus 1
mod q equal to 0. we also select a
random integer g
which must satisfy the two formulas
being mentioned on the screen right now
once these values are selected we can go
ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by x and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of 0
and the value of q the public key can be
calculated
as y equal to g to the power x mod p
where y stands for the public key the
private key can then be packaged as a
bundle which comprises of values of p
q g and x similarly
the public key can also be packaged as a
bundle having the values of p
q g and y once we're done with key
generation
we can start verifying the signature and
this generation
repeat once the keys are generated
we can start generating the signature
the message is passed through a hash
function
to generate the digest h first we can
choose any random integer k
which falls under the bracket of 0 and q
to calculate the first 160 bit number of
our signing function of
r we use the formula g to the power k
mod p
into mod q similarly to calculate the
value of the second output that is
s we use the following formula that is
shown on the screen
the signature can then be packaged as a
bundle having
r and s
this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver
now with the third phase we have to
verify the signature
we first calculate the message i just
received in the bundle
by passing it to the same hash function
we calculate the value of w
u1 and u2 using the formulas shown on
the screen
we have to calculate a verification
component which is then to be compared
with the value of r being sent by the
sender this verification component can
be calculated using the following
formula
once calculated this can be compared
with the value of
r if the values match then the signature
verification is successful
and the entire process is complete
starting from key generation
to the signature generation all the way
up to the verification of the signature
with so many steps to follow we are
bound to have a few advantages to boot
this
and we would be right to think so dsa
is highly robust in the security and
stability aspect
when compared to alternative signature
verification algorithms
we have a few other ciphers that aim to
achieve the simplicity and the
flexibility of dsa
but it has been a tough ask for all the
other suits
the key generation is much faster when
compared to the rsa algorithm and such
while the actual encryption and
decryption process may falter a little
in comparison
a quicker start in the beginning is well
known to optimize a lot of frameworks
dsa requires less storage space to work
its entire cycle
in contrast its direct correspondent
that is rsa algorithm
needs a certain amount of computational
and storage space to function
efficiently
this is not the case with dsl which has
been optimized
to work with weaker hardware and lesser
resources
the dsa is patented but nist has made
this pattern available worldwide royalty
free
a draft version of the speculation
fips1865
indicates that dsa will no longer be
approved for digital signature
generation
but it may be used to verify signatures
generated prior to the implementation
date of that standard
hope you learned something interesting
today if you have any questions
regarding this topic
please feel free to ask us in the
comments below and we will be happy to
answer your queries
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here